discours fleuve pour restaurer la
confiance dans les quartiers populaires
à tourcoing ce matin emmanuel macron a
appelé à une mobilisation nationale pour
les territoires en difficulté
aujourd'hui en france cinq millions de
personnes vivent dans 1500 quartiers les
plus pauvres
le chef de l'état espère ainsi gommer
son image de président des riches
le combat que nous devons ici conduire
c'est évidemment de restaurer la
république dans toutes ses composantes
et je ne peux pas demander un jeune de
croire dans la république quand elle
n'est pas à la hauteur
parmi les nouvelles mesures le chef de
l'état annonce le retour des emplois
francs dès le 1er janvier
lancée en 2013 le dispositif avait été
abandonnée les conditions est en trop
restrictives
cette fois les entreprises qui
recruteront dans les quartiers
populaires recevront 5000 euros par an
pendant trois ans pour une embauche en
cdi et 2500 euros par an pour un cdd de
plus de deux ans un dispositif
expérimental pour répondre aux critiques
contre la suppression des contrats aidés
un contrat aidé ce n'est pas la bonne
solution quand il n'y a pas une
formation à la clé qui permet de trouver
un emploi qui vint contrats aidés que
ceux qui les défendent les prennent il
n'en voudrait pas pour eux mêmes ils ne
veulent pas un contrat d'un an
on tremble à la fin de chaque année pour
savoir si on ne leur donnera on n'y a
pas de qualification à la fin du contrat
aidé enfin dans un contexte budgétaire
tendu
emmanuel macron a affirmé que personne
ne perdra le moindre crédit sur 2018
dans les communes concernées par la
politique de la ville enfin le chef de
l'état a promis une quinzaine de plan de
lutte contre la radicalisation d'ici au
début de l'année prochaine